the amazon is the center of the world
brazilian journalist eleni brung shared
this quote and i deeply believe it and
now we are taking you there a journey
into an alien universe
it is the heart of our planet where the
core of our biodiversity drive us with
countless eccentric and mysterious
lifeforms waiting to be discovered
but here's the twist we're actually
taking you into the amazon rainforest at
night
when night vale covers earth rainforest
becomes a new dimension where our
spectacular and ephemeral reality arises
it is when darkness falls that this
imperiled kingdom flourishes with life
beyond our imagination
i am with leo
alone on a trail at a national reserve
it is peach dark
in the deep silence we can hear chorus
of tree frogs and the footsteps of
tapirs
the decayed leaves and branches crunch
on their feet
it is hot
and humid
and the shimmering stars watches through
the dance canopy
when we turn on our flashlights there is
life
all around us
every single night as soon as the
rainforest is covered by darkness a new
world emerges bursting with life
fantastic animals that are real
extremely alive and endangered boa
snakes and kinkajous or possums and
tarantulas salamanders and moths animals
that one might see once in a lifetime as
every night the ancient and endless
forest life changes i'm a scientist
lucas is an artist and we've been
working together for six years
our expeditions take us and our partners
into the wild and we think this alien
world of tropical rainforest we're here
to show you the creature that we've
fallen completely in love with
the praying mantis
silent and scentless powerful and
patient sage our guide on this journey
through the darkness
so
why the praying mantis
well praying mantis dazzlers with their
huge eyes their tweezer-like legs their
hypnotizing swagger many of you might be
afraid of insects we used to be afraid
too
but
as we learned more about these tiny mind
beings our fear turned into passion
the search for the perimentis became a
gateway to a labyrinth of wonders in
which every corner had something new to
discover and get inspired
these
are portrayed of a variety of free
mantis specifically from the rainforests
of brazil
which one do you identify with the most
each of them could easily be a character
in a sci-fi novel
faces of the people from an exotic
planet
but we share our planet with these
creatures there are over 2 500 species
of prey menses
10 percent of them are in brazil the
most biodiverse country in the world and
we expect at least 300 more species to
be discovered there
we within their microwork they are fused
predators hunting down any creature they
can grasp from mosquitoes to cicadas and
even though rarely vertebrates such as
frogs and birds they can eat anything
from softening yummy flies to armored
plated beetles they can even eat and
process poisonous caterpillars without
harming themselves and last year we just
published that the first ever account of
a praying mantis feeding on plant sap
a vegetarian mantis
well
when walking this alien world questions
arise more often than answers speaking
of poison they have none in their bodies
so they rely on the physical strength of
their spiky legs called raptorios and
their swift moves to catch their prey
their vision is highly accurate
precisely detecting that through a
unique to a division system in the
animal kingdom which reacts to movement
their eyes seem to adapt to the light
changing color between day and night but
we're still unsure how good their night
vision is despite seeing them actively
roam around in darkness
most of them are masters of camouflage
and ancient art meaningful on the native
habitat this colorful mayo vanishes on
the aggressive fields where he lives
can you spot a praying mantis on these
pictures
yes
no
well actually these photos are
exclusively a free mantises the first
looks like a dry leaf the second like a
stick and the third like lichen
their shape has ranged from fresh green
leaves mosses branches
to everything in between we are blown
away by how evolution led these
incredible predators to blend into the
natural environment
and if they feel tread net they can play
dead
or display colors like a peacock
all within an extremely light body large
males like this eight centimeters long
can weight just one gram others are even
smaller
the more permanent changes they go
through are just as awesome
like other insects they grow through
mouths changing their skin and when
adults developing wings depending on
their species
since the very beginning of
progettomanchus six years ago we've
taken care of every mantis we've
collected for research they live in our
homes with us
our family and friends think of them as
pets this unusual no cue protocol allows
us to understand about their life cycles
behavior and perhaps more important to
connect them to people around us
back home there are over four immenses
waiting for us and some we live for over
two years
this year we just discovered a new
species this tiny green mantis has a
translucent body and intrigues us
because it was found only through our
known little light strap which attract
winged males we believe it lives high up
in the canopy out of our sight
and despite the advances of technology
allowing humanity to explore the deep
sea
the outer space the metaverse now
we still lack efficient tools to
research and survey the highest parts of
amazonia which is exactly where
scientists expect to find the greatest
biodiversity in the world forest
on our last expedition we tried night
drone flights
without success
the creative uses of technology are part
of our contemporary science and we keep
chasing ideas that could lead us to
explore the unreachable treetops and
understand more and more about menses in
the wild
the closer you look
the more beautiful complexity you will
find like this amazing roll of prime
mantis's wings
and there's the brazilian dragon mantis
the flower bird mantis the unicorn
but
of course
rainforest isn't just a fantasy
wonderland what if you are afraid of the
dark you might be wondering well the
answer is the same among explorers
out there
surrounded by all kinds of creatures
the only thing we fear
is mankind
and when we are back home we fear
that the next time you visit the
rainforest again it will be further
destroyed
rainforests are delicate and endangered
ecosystems critical to the stability of
our planet most of its life remains
unknown
and just during this single talk we've
lost about 15 hectares of rainforest in
the ammos of brazil to the first station
that's bigger than 20 football fields
every 10 minutes
countless spring months is gone
no matter how magical darkness is
when it covers the amazon tonight
these areas will be empty
a silent warning that few will hear
we are documenting speeches that may not
exist in future generations we're just
beginning to learn about them and we are
sharing our discoveries so that we can
increase their chances of survival
last october we'll add our national
geographically funded expedition amazon
from dusk to dawn with a team of amazing
scientists and storytellers eager to
find new ways of exploring the night and
here
for the first time
you're going to see what happens when we
expose fragments to pure ultraviolet
light
they all shine it back to us
in colors we could have never even
dreamed of
a brilliant blue in some species a soft
and warming orange in others and then
all at once on this beautiful herd and
mantis
these colors are real technology allowed
us to see them with our naked eyes a
visible and magical fluorescence
even the dead leaf mantis was suddenly
sparkling
like liquid fire
and to our delight
the whole jungle
evaporated in unimaginable colors
where are they trying to communicate
which other secrets are we missing and
yet again rainforest at night shows us
how little we understand about its
beauty
with hundreds of hours of nocturnal
dives our expeditions are filled with
wonders in a rainforest zootopia
we are hoping these discoveries will
kick off this new era where science arts
technology will bloom again in favor of
nature
the age of exploration on planet earth
is far from over
and in the nights of the rainforest it
is just beginning
thank you
you